well
the health district of southern
nevadas is tracking data on the
new variant of kobe from omicron that
is greeted by cristian cásseres with
super informative from kirchner in spanish
the centers for
prevention and disease control recommend
continuing with the same precautions
implemented  since the beginning of the
pandemic, in addition to receiving
the cob vaccine and using a face mask in
closed places and always keeping your
distance, the governor tips is the signature of
a new emergency guideline
allowing children under 12
years of age to attend large events,
ruling out  your vaccination status
however you will still have to use the face
mask
especially if you are not vaccinated and the
party starts this wednesday starting
at 6pm with the
downtown holden event located above freeman
suites a free celebration at the
end of the show  final of the
national rodeo the beach hotel will be
illuminating  the sky with fireworks
and we close by taking a look at the
temperatures for this first of
December as we can see we will
have a few sunny days with
temperatures around 70 degrees
the winds will return and the temperatures will drop
for next week I am
Cristian Cásseres with your but
informative news  in spanish good day